hey I've gained a lot of ground in the  polls that's good news yeah I have you  down only four points but they're having  a ton of new negative ads maybe I should  fight back  man your heart's in the right place your  heart and your butt I will not go  negative crap on a turd care for a  recall nope  gift bag the committee to recall Leslie  Knope is relentless  look what they're handing out in  elementary schools I'm Leslie Knope tell  your parents to recall me we all know  that I cannot spend as much money on ads  as my opponent but I printed out 10,000  don't stickers and 10,000 question mark  stickers that way if you see a sign that  says recall Knope all you need to do is  add the question mark and the don't and  suddenly it reads recall nope don't why  don't you just put the dome in front of  recall note yep that's a much better  idea can I have these question marks  occurs why I want to put them on stop  signs  you